[Music]
we are live on the air at the moment do
you mind telling me why i'm under arrest
sir
that reporter was just taken into police
custody
live on television
as journalists we can't let the truth
down we are moderators of fact
government attacking journalists is not
new
this is happening widespread also
[Music]
the president of brazil is saying that
i'm a [ __ ]
in the constitution freedom of the press
is guaranteed
but the rules are changing
the problem is the lack of public trust
in journalism i'm not gonna buy a
newspaper that doesn't reflect my view
sometimes it feels like when you talk to
people you're living in two different
realities if you want to talk to me you
can take the mask off
you can never tell what threats are
going to materialize on the ground
my 30 years of experience i have not
seen this amount of harassment it's not
even erasmus intimidation
it's so difficult to know if this is the
end of an era or the beginning of
something even more sinister
press freedom in the united states
is starting to look like many other
countries around the world
[Music]
that profound crisis
it's not going away
you